What is it real alpha-male? Well actually
I don't like that name alpha-male
because so many people don't understand
the true meaning of what it means to be
an alpha male. You know who I'm talking
about... you've met them.
Those self-proclaimed, self-professed
alpha males that are not really alpha
males but just arrogant fools. Or should I
say dumb bullies. So what is a real alpha
male? Well, let's get into the video
I've seen a lot of talk on alpha males
in the comments and a lot of different
videos and also just on social media and
the things that I've read is just
mind-blowing... So what is a real alpha
male? Is it a guy that bullies those
around him to get what he wants? Is it
the guy that's big and strong and
laughs and breaks down those who are
weaker than him? Or is he the one that
tries to show off and impress other
people by doing stupid things? No. A real
alpha male is a great leader! It's
somebody that really cares about other
people. We're not animals. We're humans
So what makes a alpha male a great
leader? Well let's start with the first
characteristic
Honesty and integrity. People only really
follow a leader if he shows that he can
be trusted. This means that a real alpha male will
act on his values instead of his
personal gain...
He inspires others. He doesn't break them
down emotionally or psychologically or
physically. There's a lot of guys out there
that think if they act aggressively and
arrogant and breaking people down that
they are alpha male but if you live this
way, you should look behind you because you'll realize that there's nobody following
you. Because nobody likes to follow an
arrogant self-absorbed fool. A real alpha
male inspires others to dream more, learn
more, do more and to become more. They unlock
people's potential to become better
Accountability. A real alpha male knows
that leadership is a lot more than just
about power. It's about vision and
accountability. He accepts responsibility
for his actions and he owns his mistakes.
Wise. He sees the bigger picture and he
understand that it is more important to
become a man of value compared to a man of success. This is actually one of the
smartest things Albert Einstein said
He has commitment and passion. He doesn't fear commitment because the only thing
he fears is wasting his time and he
moves forward with great passion because
he knows that GREAT MEN are men who moves forward with REAL passion
They have charisma. Fake alpha males they don't have charisma. They just dumb
bullies that nobody likes.
Simply put people are more likely to
follow the lead of somebody that they
like. The best leaders are well-spoken
friendly and approachable. They are this
way not because it's an act but because
they really genuinely care about people
Decisiveness. A real alpha-male is capable of making good decisions. Because they
know if things are not gonna work out
great they'll need to hold themselves
accountable and they accept the risks.
Many people cannot do that
Empowerment. He does not bully others to force them to do his bidding. No! Leaders become great leaders
not because of their power
but because they have the ability to
empower other people to become great
themselves.
Confidence
The alpha male doesn't try to improve
his position by talking big about
himself or puffing himself up in front
of other people. Only insecure people do
that. The real alpha male is self-aware
and content with himself. He's confident
in himself because he knows his
strengths and weaknesses. Great leaders
know that they don't need to try and act
tough like fake alpha males because they
know that their confidence and humility
underscores their toughness
Empathy. If you don't have empathy you
can never become a great leader
Why? Because understanding the problems of other people and and also feeling
their pain is the first step to become a
great leader and if people see that they
will gladly follow him.
Now just a bonus tip and this is very important so listen up:
Fake alpha males cannot control their
emotions. Great leaders... they learn how to
control not only their emotions but also
their thoughts. Because they know that
out of  control thoughts or emotions makes
smart men stupid...